this video is sponsored by morning brew
billions of years after the beginning of
time after countless species had emerged
and died cosmic wars have been fought
and lost and galactic empires had risen
and fallen in a remote region of the
cosmos there lived a being by the name
of nobus
nobis was a descendant of one of the
first sentient species to ever emerge in
the universe and one of the first
species to ever successfully evolve and
make it past the great filters of
existence his ancestors had built
technologies and uncovered knowledge
needed to harness the energy of their
star spread out beyond their host solar
system and extend individual lifespans
well into the hundreds of thousands of
years
nobis was conceived during a time that
was marked by a new wave of compounding
progress and ingenuity the likes of
which the universe had never seen before
novices father came from a lineage of
high-ranking fleet commanders and was
now the leader of a newly emerging
galactic empire
and so from birth nobis was prophesized
to be a ruler of a new form
with the insistent pressure and
expectations of his father and family
name with which nothing was ever good
enough and ordained by his circumstances
of time and space nobus would grow up to
become one of the most advanced members
of his already hyper-advanced species
inheriting his father's position of
immense power and yearn
as leader nobis dedicated himself to
growth and progress determined to prove
that he was worthy worthy of his role
worthy of his name worthy of existence
worthy of his father's love
nobusus's goal was not to become leader
of his father's nation nor leader of a
species though
rather he would not be satisfied until
he was the leader of the entire universe
working relentlessly every day nobis
left no celestial stone unturned
amassing every possible resource and
uncovering every possible insight he
traveled the entire galaxy then the
entire galaxy cluster and then the
entire universe he met with every
important sentient being across the
cosmos overcame those who challenged him
and allied with those who did not he
climbed the ranks of his entire species
and then the ranks of all species he
learned everything there was to know
every law of physics every rule of
reality he learned how it was all put
together and how it all worked he
transcended and merged with other minds
forming into a single mind that
encompassed all thoughts and all
timelines he harnessed the energy of
stars then galaxies and then the whole
universe integrating with its very
fabric like a seamster of reality
nobis would emerge monarch of the cosmos
deity of celestial bodies
god of time and space
ensuring that the cosmos continue to run
smoothly however proved to be quite a
lot of work ensuring that celestial
bodies moved properly that resources
were distributed and allocated equitably
that civilizations both new and old were
operating appropriately staying out of
each other's way satisfied but not too
satisfied and so on meant that nobis now
spent most of his time behind a desk
inside an office atop a tower going
through documents running calculations
dealing with problems and making
decisions
of course nobis could have and did have
help from other advanced species and
beings whom he had allied with along the
way but since he took his job very
seriously and believed that he was the
only being in the universe capable of
making sure that things were done right
he always checked over everyone's
documents and calculations and required
his approval for all decisions
consequently those who work for nobis
were only of so much help
most of those who worked for or knew of
nobis envied him although no one ever
seriously thought that they could take
his job they desired it they desired his
success and his position in the cosmos
they envied his immense power and
influence they envied his freedom and
autonomy
in truth however nobis didn't derive
much pleasure from his role at all he
was always busy and being responsible
for everything involved endless tedium
and bureaucracy
of course he could have relinquished his
title and responsibilities but he was
far too prideful he could not imagine
making it this far just to go the other
way
what would the rest of the universe
think of him nobody wants to hear the
complaints of a god
moreover he feared what would happen no
one else could do what he could no one
else should he felt it was what he had
dedicated his existence to what he was
good at what he understood what he was
supposed to do
and so he did the work because it was
his to do
after billions of years into managing
the universe nobis still had not taken
much if any time off
he hadn't explored much of the cosmos in
a very very long time let alone enjoyed
much of it
occasionally he would take a day or week
off every thousand years or so but he
would often just find himself feeling
guilty and anxious when he did he
typically just ended up working from
whatever utopian oasis he was at in
whatever other remote part of the
universe just the same
he feared that if he took too much time
off he would lose control he would lose
traction that things would go wrong in
the hands of others
and so after beating the infinitesimal
odds of existing surviving millions of
years of chaos and acquiring the powers
of a god nobis spent his time working
incessantly day in and day out toiling
away at a tedious ceaseless piling of
work and bureaucracy never really even
enjoying the very universe he governed
he figured that at the end of time when
there was no more work to be done and no
more things to manage
then
you would finally find a moment to take
a quick trip around the universe and
enjoy the remaining stars and
destinations
just before they ended
forever
thank you so much for watching this
video was sponsored by the completely
free business tech and finance
newsletter morningbrew
the developments and shifts in the world
of technology and business are both
overwhelming and extremely exciting
every day new things happen that shake
the world new technologies businesses
economic shifts and so on however the
news can often be more confusing and
chaotic than helpful and enjoyable
morningbrew solves this problem by
filtering and summarizing the most
relevant news in tech business and
finance into short enjoyable and often
witty newsletters delivered to your
inbox daily without morning brew getting
the news often involves aimlessly
scrolling or tediously watching formats
filled with white noise and excessive
information with morning brew however
you can stay up to date on just what
you're interested in in as little as
five minutes
recently morning brew has made it easy
to follow major developments in tech and
science like how ai is being used in
various applications how businesses are
disrupting the medical industry with
more affordable medications how crispr
or gene editing technology has changed
and is likely to change in the future
and much more
turn your mornings into opportunities to
be more interested knowledgeable and
excited about the events of the world
with morning brew today by using the
link in the description below it takes
just 15 seconds to sign up and is
completely free
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
you